what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
yesterday a lot happened for spider-man
no way home we basically got
confirmation that toby maguire and
andrew garfield are indeed going to be
in the film and i have a slight trailer
update today we're going to take it as a
rumor but it's actually a pretty cool
rumor about when sony might be releasing
that spider-man no way home second
trailer the first official full-length
trailer and i'll give you a little hint
before we get into it it has something
to do with stan lee so pretty cool news
to talk about there there's also a new
scene that everybody is apparently
talking about and some merch released
online yesterday for spider-man no way
home and of course i'll be breaking it
all down in this video and if you're new
and you love spider-man be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
we are giving away a bring variant arts
action figure of spider-man himself all
you have to do to enter subscribe to my
channel and my other channel that's run
by chris cosmic culture so we're
definitely going to be getting into what
i believe is a pretty big confirmation
of toby and andrew and spiderman no way
home but first let's talk about an
interesting trailer release date rumor
and i want to stress that it is a rumor
at this point in time i've actually not
been able to track down the original
person who reported this a lot of people
have just been tweeting this on twitter
and putting it on instagram stating that
this is a rumor of when the release date
could be coming out but i actually kind
of like the idea of it which is why i
want to talk about it because the rumor
states that the final trailer of
spider-man no way home which will also
be the first official full-length
trailer will be released on november
12th in honor of stan lee if you are not
aware of the significance of november
12th stan lee passed away on november
12th of 2018 three years ago and i don't
think stan lee needs an introduction i
think most people know who stan lee is
but him and steve ditko did create
spider-man just one of both of their
many accomplishments but i gotta say i
do really like this idea of the
spider-man no way home final trailer
coming out on november 12th to honor
stan lee i wish it was coming from a
pretty credible source to tell you that
there's a good chance of this happening
but right now again it's just a rumor
although it does kind of fall into the
timeline that some people like daniel
rpk have been saying stating that the
trailer is probably coming within two to
three weeks so this is a rumor for now
but keep an eye out on that date
november 12th and of course if i hear
anything about that trailer release date
whatsoever i'll be sure to update
everybody and now for some more concrete
spider-man news that i talked about in
the beginning and this really is
exciting so right off the bat many of
you probably saw the leaked pictures of
the green goblins costume and the three
spider-man costumes i talked about this
a couple of days ago but the actual
photos of these are out they've been
leaked everywhere online right now now i
can't show them because they are
definitely not supposed to be out there
in the public and the studios would get
super mad not to mention people are
definitely going to be getting fired and
i do not want to contribute to that but
it's basically out there now we've seen
three different spider-man suits and a
new suit for the green goblin which as i
mentioned the other day is pretty much
the same just a little different in
small ways but it looks very very good
and it doesn't actually seem like the
green goblin is going to be wearing a
mask that much looks like he's actually
going to be wearing a hood at some point
in time the suit's a little bit up and
some parts of it have been replaced and
it looks like he's going to be wearing
some type of a bag most likely to put
his pumpkin bombs in and at one point in
time it looks like he might have a
purple scarf and this will kind of serve
as a hood slash cape now the other
picture that leaked was of toby maguire
spider-man outfit and andrew garfield
spiderman outfit one of the pictures was
them sitting right next to tom's outfit
all of them hanging right next to each
other and from what we know these photos
are indeed real and they do match the
description that was given to us a
couple of days ago it is very clear that
these are the photos that everybody has
been talking about now the suits pretty
much look the same it looks like toby
maguire suit from the sam raimi universe
and it looks like the last suit that we
saw andrew garfield wearing in the
amazing spider-man universe it's
exciting and yes we may have seen andrew
garfield in the suit already in that
leaked video but we have yet to see
anything with toby we had one leaked
photo a few months ago but it was very
blurry and hard to make out and we kind
of saw his hand but that's pretty much
it but let's talk about what this photo
of these two other suits means it is
basically a confirmation that they are
in the film these are not suits that tom
holland is going to be wearing these are
very clearly the suits of tobey maguire
and andrew garfield just another
confirmation that the two of them are
going to be in the film we've pretty
much gotten a confirmation from almost
every source except from the studios
marvel studios and sony of course but
hopefully that comes soon hopefully that
comes with the second trailer now
speaking of trailers there is a scene
that has been leaked that is going
around online right now that a lot of
people have been asking me about
claiming that it is leaked footage from
the second trailer i kind of addressed
this before but in case some people
didn't see the video that is actually
from the first trailer it's cut footage
that didn't make it to the final cut of
the first trailer the scene shows doctor
strange opening a portal right in front
of the sanctum and going through the
portal this is apparently when he steps
onto the train and as we've seen from
the first trailer he then duplicates the
train works a lot of sorcery and
apparently it looks like he's going to
be fighting peter parker we have heard
several leaks that state that dr strange
and peter are going to fight in the
beginning of the film this is due to the
spell going wrong and bringing some
villains from their universes into rmcu
once they get in our universe doctor
strange is going to hold them prisoners
after all that's kind of his job as a
master of the mystic arts and as he told
tony stark in the beginning of avengers
infinity war his job is to protect
everyone's reality so immediately doctor
strange is kind of going to lock all the
villains up but then peter parker starts
to feel kind of guilty because they kind
of mention that spider-man killed them
all in their universes so spider-man
kind of wants to let them go this is
kind of largely due to the green goblin
manipulating him but from what we know
eventually he ends up fighting with
doctor strange and consequently the
villains get released so that brief tiny
little scene where doctor strange opens
up a portal and then jumps on the train
which we have seen before the only part
that's really different is doctor
strange opening the portal which we've
seen a billion times but apparently this
scene is when doctor strange and
spider-man are going to fight and i'm
probably betting on doctor strange i'm
gonna go ahead and say he wins and from
here this is where the villains will get
loose and the two of them have to work
together and come up with a plan to get
them back and stop them now the final
thing we'll talk about is something that
happened yesterday and that is that a
lot of spider-man no way home merch
dropped on amazon yesterday and this is
good news one because well we can buy
spider-man home merch now but two this
is a very good indicator that the
promotion for the movie is about to step
up a little bit and they really do plan
to release that trailer relatively soon
but if you take a quick look at the
spider-man know a home merch that is on
amazon we can see a few different things
here we have some figures for spider-man
mj doctor strange ned jj even and some
really cool suits one suit shows the
face of spider-man in his gold and black
suit and around it it says spider-man
peter parker now it's a t-shirt but to
me this is kind of reflective of the
movie everybody is going to know that
peter parker is spider-man that's kind
of the whole deal of him going to doctor
strange and asking him to make people
forget that he is spider-man and quick
little note one thing that cracks me up
is they are selling other spider-man no
way home merch that is not official they
are actually using fan art to sell
things such as notebooks and posters
which is hilarious and i still cannot
believe that we don't even have an
official poster for the film but merch
is coming out official merch is coming
out which means things are about to get
very very real that first trailer should
be here and we should be getting an
official poster very very soon so in the
meantime let me know what you think
about all of this news in the comments
down below don't forget to subscribe and
don't forget to hit that like button if
you enjoyed this video for live updates
you can follow me on instagram twitter
and tick tock and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
you